¿Qué pasa, pizarritas? Vamos allá con un nuevo Q&A bastante completito donde vamos a hablar de la Liga, de fútbol internacional, de la selección y de muchas cosas más.
Con Adrián Blanco, Álex de Llano y Nahuel Miranda. ¿Qué tal chicos, cómo estáis?
¿Qué tal chicos, muy buenas? ¿Cómo estamos?
¿Qué tal, buenas tardes? Bueno, buenas tardes, buenos días.
Sí, bueno, es que...
Estamos hablando por la tarde y concretamente del lunes.
Exactamente, o sea, fíjate qué día menos viernes que el lunes.
Pero, pero, bueno, yo ahora mismo, en viernes, estoy en una bonita isla española llamada Mallorca, solucionando...
Me han llamado para solucionar un lío que tienen por allí, por la isla, no quiero dar más detalles, pero bueno, voy como mediador de conflicto, ¿vale?
Hermano mayor, vas de hermano mayor.
Ostras, molaría, molaría mucho.
Creo que va algo para hermano mayor, o sea, un poquito Pedro Aguado.
Dani Rodríguez, eh, pegando portazos.
¡Que quiero jugar!
Te voy a decir una cosa, Dani, te voy a decir una cosa, escúchame.
Bueno, a ver...
Dani, te voy a recoger basura.
Va jugando con la alegría de mis hijos.
Dejadme que antes de empezar con las primeras preguntas, recuerde a nuestros pizarritas que estamos organizando un sorteo con los amigos de Gambea, ¿eh?
¿Aquí, dónde está? Aquí, aquí.
¿Dónde? A ver...
También el escudo, pero el escudo de la marca.
Aquí somos románticos y mercenarios al mismo tiempo.
Estamos organizando un concurso en el que regalamos una equipación personalizada by Gambea a vuestro equipo, vuestro grupo de amigos, o para ti.
Defeías soltero.
Imagínate que no tienes colegas, pero quieres una equipación repetida, 13 buques.
El otro día se me ocurrió una idea.
Para... Hay muchas familias que en Nochebuena, en lugar de hacer una Nochebuena tal, hacen juegos, ¿no?
Sí.
Pues que tengan la equipación.
La equipación de la abuela, ¿eh?
Claro, la equipación de la abuela...
No, no.
Es esta chula.
Con el 99.
Para lo que vosotros queráis, estamos buscando la respuesta más original.
El 79.
El abuelo que no... Abuelo, el 88, no.
Que no.
Estamos...
Es un mismo angeliño, ¿eh?
Estamos buscando la respuesta más original con el nombre del equipo, con la justificación.
En nuestro Instagram, somospizzarritas, y en Instagram de Gambea, GambeaSop, lo estamos mostrando ahora mismo en pantalla.
Y para motivaros, enseñan a Uel Miranda la camiseta del mejor equipo madrileño en general.
Las cobayas, ¿vale?
Son unas cobayas muy ganadoras y muy habilidosas a esto del balonpied.
Sí.
Que son el panatináutico.
¡Bah!
¡Qué guapa, eh!
La primera equipación.
¡Espectacular!
Hemos hecho primera y segunda.
Sí.
Bueno, muy chula, muy chula.
Muy chulas.
Así que, pizarritas, si queréis tener una, no del panati.
Aunque me parece que hay planes de expansión de marca al respecto.
Bueno, vaya pedido hicimos.
El primer pedido.
Por eso digo...
Unas cuantas.
Si queréis un premio top, pues ya sabéis, en nuestro Instagram tenéis el concurso.
En este Q&A tenéis grandes preguntas y ya veremos si grandes respuestas.
Esto tampoco lo podemos asegurar.
La primera gran cuestión.
¿Por qué se habla, Miguel?
¿Qué?
Desde que Gambea y panatináutico se han juntado sus caminos, dices bien el nombre, eh.
Ya te he dicho.
Anda, anda.
Mercenario.
La plata baila el mono, eh.
Exactamente.
¡Hombre, hombre!
El monito Lo Celso, eh.
El monito Lo Celso.
Como le recordó un buen amigo hace poquito.
Un buen amigo de Lo Celso, no mío.
Valentín Gómez.
No sé si fue Valentín Gómez o quién fue.
Entonces, he tirado por...
La foto era Valentín.
Muy bien, muy bien.
Mas Sopenga pregunta.
Eh...
Bueno, me he inventado el nombre.
Max...
¿Sopenga o Sopenya?
No, no, que me lo he inventado directamente.
Max Soprendrei.
Son preguntas del YouTube.
Vale, y aquí la gente tiene extraños.
Porque YouTube es...
Es un lugar...
Parece un traniano, ¿no?
Es un lugar que solo tiene un canal de luz,
el resto es oscuridad.
Pregunta.
Yo creo que es Max Sopenya-Rey.
O Sopena.
Ah, puede ser.
Es Sopenya.
Puede ser.
Bueno, ¿qué es su pregunta?
¿Qué es lo importante?
Viendo el bajísimo nivel de Dani Olmo,
esta temporada acabará Fermín siendo titular en el Barça de Flick.
Peligra su importancia en clave selección.
Es uno de los temas de los que venimos hablando, Adri.
Yo sigo pensando
que el techo del Barça es con Dani Olmo.
No ya por Dani Olmo, sino por cómo mejora el resto.
Pero es verdad que ahora mismo no tengo ningún tipo de duda.
Vamos a pensar.
Clásico, por ejemplo, ¿no?
Que es uno de los siguientes grandes partidos del Fútbol Club Barcelona.
Yo pongo a Fermín antes que a Dani Olmo.
Pero además, es que ni me lo pienso.
De calle.
Sí, a corto plazo.
Si Dani Olmo no revuenta el vuelo
y Fermín se recupera bien de su lesión,
creo que Fermín tiene papeletas de ser titular
en la media punta.
No creo que peligre el puesto de Dani Olmo en la selección.
Tendría que alargar esta mala dinámica
durante todos los meses de competición
y que Luis de la Fuente lo vea muy mal mentalmente.
Que ojo, Adri.
Realmente, supuesto...
Claro, su puesto en la convocatoria
yo creo que no peligra de ninguna de las maneras.
Pero ese puesto que se había ganado en la Eurocopa
como media punta después de la lesión de Pedri,
ese puesto ya no lo tiene
porque Pedri ha bajado a la base sin Fabián
y está Miquel Merino.
Sí, sí.
Está Merino que rindió muy bien en el último par de selecciones
como ese futbolista interior más llegador
o ese media punta que jugaba más cerca del delantero.
Dicho lo cual, a mí ya sabéis
que me gustaría empezar a ver esta temporada a la MIM por dentro.
Si no remonta el vuelo Dani Olmo
y no da con la tecla hands-shift para la media punta,
a mí me gustaría pensar que la 25-26
va a ser la primera temporada donde empecemos a ver
a la MIM ya mal jugando en el carrego central.
Yo solo quiero...
Lo de Pedri la abre hueco a la MIM.
A mí, perdona, a Dani Olmo, realmente.
Pero antes compartía posición y ahora ya no.
Sí, sí, pero te quiero decir que estamos viendo a Miquel Merino.
O sea, por eso digo que...
Y es la posición donde hay más candidatos, ¿no?
Sí, porque puede jugar a Ibaena, porque...
De acuerdo.
Yo creo que lo 8...
Quiero decir, la posición de Fabián,
que era claramente Fabián, que no va en este parón,
bueno, donde hemos visto a Pedri,
donde puede entrar Pablo Barrios,
que es, yo creo, de los que llegan más en forma esta convocatoria,
donde hemos visto también a Merino, aunque últimamente viene jugando más de 10.
Yo creo que el 8 sí que está muy bien cubierto,
el 10 yo tengo alguna duda más.
Yo creo que con recuperación de Fermín,
que con la recuperación de Fermín, la recuperación de Isco,
con Baena...
Fíjate, tres jugadores que han entrado en las últimas convocatorias.
Pero, pero...
Pero, Álex, yo no creo...
Yo no creo que vaya a sacar a Dani Olmo por Isco,
y no porque no se lo vaya a merecer Isco,
o porque no se merezca Dani Olmo salir de la convocatoria,
sino por un tema de engranaje colectivo y de respuesta...
Pero no estoy hablando de la convocatoria,
hablo de hueco en el 11.
O sea, que ya me parecen que son tres opciones,
más Olmo, más teniendo en cuenta
que no vaya a ser capaz Luis de la Fuente
de buscarle a convivencia a Fabián Pedri...
Que esta es otra.
Que eso va a suceder, pero que los últimos parones
no lo ha podido realizar por el estado físico de Fabián.
Y yo, sinceramente, lo que tengo dudas es de...
O sea, yo confío mucho en el Dani Olmo,
creo que en el Dani Olmo futbolista,
creo que el Dani Olmo media punta es el media punta perfecto
tanto para el Barça como para España,
porque es un futbolista que te lidera desde la presión,
que te recupera balones, que te da muchísimo giro,
que fluye en toda la línea de media punta,
que tiene gol, que tiene último pase,
pero es que ahora mismo no se parece nada al Dani Olmo,
ni el de 2021, ni de 2020...
A mí me sorprende, Álex, me sorprende,
porque yo me creía mucho esa celebración
que hacía al estilo Lílar, Dani Olmo,
indicando el reloj como mi momento ha llegado,
porque él quería volver a Barcelona,
venía de una Eurocopa absolutamente top,
su primer impacto en el Barça es sobresaliente,
por no decir de matrícula de honor,
y no me refiero solo al primer partido en Vallecas,
sino a los primeros compases,
pero se ha caído sin que tampoco haya tenido
excesivo problema de lesiones.
Sabemos que él sigue teniendo de vez en cuando,
pero yo el otro día en Twitter le leía
a uno de mis Twitteros cooles de referencia,
que es Vieja Europa, decir que Dani Olmo,
irónicamente, está jugando por las lesiones.
Es que esa es la realidad, es que si no Dani Olmo,
no estaría jugando, entonces está teniendo continuidad,
está teniendo por detrás a Pedro y Frankie De Jong
que funcionan muy bien, y en el Barça ha ido perdiendo espacio,
pero es que en la selección, si retrocedemos antes,
antes de esa Eurocopa, Dani Olmo jugaba muchísimo
en banda izquierda, esa ya es la posición de Nico,
pero es que por ejemplo en esta convocatoria,
en este parón, mañana hay partido de la selección española,
ya veremos que alinea Luis de la Fuente,
pero a mí se me ocurren mejores ideas
que poner a Dani Olmo en banda izquierda,
que en otra convocatoria sin Nico y sin Lamin,
todos tendríamos claro que a izquierda va Dani Olmo,
y a mí se me ocurre poner a Yabaena,
poner en derecha a Pino, jugar con Jesús,
claro, jugar con Jesús de cara a un mejor nivel
porque Dani Olmo es que está desconocido,
y tú repasabas el otro día los datos, sales en la pizarra,
está interviniendo bastante, o sea, no es un tema casi de cantidad,
sino de calidad en las intervenciones.
Está interviniendo más por 90,
estos datos que lo basan todos los 90 minutos,
está interviniendo más en el último tercio,
pero aún así le está costando más tener impacto,
sí que es verdad que le estamos viendo jugar más minutos,
quizá jugar minutos que son más complicados de destacar,
es decir, que el equipo igual está un poco más cerrado,
que no termina de ver esos espacios,
pero aún así yo entiendo que estamos viendo un Dani Olmo
que nos está dejando bastante a deber.
Está dejando a deber, sí, Dani Olmo y la cámara de...
Nahuel Miranda, pero ha vuelto, ahí le tenemos.
Ha vuelto, ha vuelto. Más suegra que nunca.
Segunda cuestión, Luca Tobillos, por ejemplo, tenía que ir a Arnau,
déjame tirarme la pared a mí mismo.
Vamos a hablar de suegras, la segunda pregunta, claro.
Dice Luca Tobillos, no sé si es la suegra o el qué,
porque dice, soy de la Real Sociedad.
La suegra Francisco, ¿eh?
Y dice, creo que la culpa no la tiene Sergio Francisco,
pero distituyéndole sería la manera más directa de intentar cambiar algo,
aprovechando el parón y pregunta si lo haríamos para traer un nuevo entrenador
y que tenga estos días para trabajar seriamente en el proyecto.
Insistimos en que nosotros estamos grabando esto el lunes y lo digo
porque hay run run en San Sebastián.
Yo creo que no va a pasar, pero ya hay run run
y sabéis que el run run es el anticipo o el paso previo al comunicado.
O mejor dicho, el run run es previo a la ratificación
y la ratificación al comunicado de destitución.
Pero sí que es verdad que somos un poquito negativos, chicos,
así a nivel general, porque es que no estamos viendo mucho cambio,
no estamos viendo que haya roto con la mala dinámica futbolística y emocional.
Sólo Ander Barremechea ha mejorado prestaciones.
A mí me sorprende mucho que no esté agitando al equipo a nivel táctico.
Estamos viendo y lo hemos analizado en las últimas semanas,
nuevos posicionamientos tácticos en campo rival,
equipos que cierran a un lateral, que lo utilizan para una cosa, para otra.
Tienes ahí a Sergio Gómez, que creo que es un futbolista
con el que podrías jugar precisamente a algo parecido.
Y estamos viendo a la misma Real Sociedad, con matices evidentemente,
pero a la misma Real Sociedad partido tras partido.
Y eso no funciona. Ahora mismo no funciona.
Igual con Jan Gell y con dos semanas con Carlos Soler, etc.
La cosa crece, mejora, ganas partidos y cambia.
Pero de momento no hemos visto ningún tipo de avance.
Y este inmovilismo a nivel táctico es extraño,
porque recuerdo durante el verano hablar con John Cuesba en la pizarra
y que John me contase de los primeros partidos de Sergio Francisco,
que estaba siendo muy intervencionista,
que estaba aprobando distintos sistemas, incluso durante los partidos,
que le estaban metiendo mano al equipo para tratar de dar con la tecla,
de encajar todas las piezas y de ver otra nueva forma de jugar para la Real Sociedad.
Pero no es así.
Yo creo que el cambio en el banquillo no ha provocado el efecto deseado,
sobre todo a nivel anímico.
No ha cambiado nada.
Sigue siendo una Real que transmite muy poquito,
como en la segunda vuelta de la temporada pasada.
Y llegado a estas alturas,
yo me temo que va a tener difícil solución.
La cuestión con Sergio Francisco, ojalá me equivoque,
pero creo que si no ha encontrado ella la tecla y la cosa no está mejorando
y la Real está donde está en la clasificación,
entendería perfectamente que se pulse el botón, la verdad.
Es el peor arranque de la Real Sociedad en los últimos 20 años.
Citaban como cosa de este arranque en el diario Vasco,
lo comparaban con el arranque de Yago Barrasate en la 14-15,
que terminó siendo destituido en el mes de noviembre.
Entonces, bueno, es una situación, yo creo, que algo complicada.
De hecho, Alex le leía a Badagio en marca que Yago Barrasate fue destituido en la jornada 10
y David Moyes en la 11.
Lo digo por entender un poco tiempos,
o tiempo, mejor dicho, que ha ido manejando Joaquín Aperriba.
O sea, que puede ser que Francisco puede moverse ahí, ¿no?
Puede tener este parón para terminar de ajustar.
Oye, a ver, Yang Hen, a ver cómo termina.
Pero igual en el de noviembre, Caput.
Pero sí, o sea...
No tendría nada a ver en el mercado de entrenadores libres,
entrenadores que de todas, todas digas...
Sí, a por él. Sí, a juego.
Porque creo que, oye, una vez a por Caput, Francisco no te sale,
creo que tienes que ir a por un nombre un poquito más contrastado.
¿Cuál has dicho, Alex, de Tapadillo?
Setién. Enrique.
Se ha quedado libre ahora porque se ha ido de Beijing.
O han promotido personales, ¿no?
Sí, pero...
Quien sigue más la Liga china sabe que se iban a cepillar
más pronto que tarde a Albuero de Quique.
Bueno, hablando en serio...
Sí, no lo digo porque como ha salido la noticia esta,
ya he visto a algún aficionado de la Real Sociedad en Twitter diciendo...
¡Ay, Dios, no!
No tiene pinta, que no pase esto.
No tiene pinta.
Está por ahí García Pimienta, está Luis García Plaza, está Raúl...
Raúl.
No me termina de convencer ninguno.
¿Y del extranjero, Nao?
¿Y del extranjero?
A mí hay más opciones.
A mí hay un alemán que me gusta.
Pero...
No sé si es una certeza en este momento...
¿Quién?
¿Marco Rose? Sí.
Es que aquí... Yo la hablaba con John Quetzval
el otro día tras el partido.
Y...
Teorizábamos de si hubiese un entrenador
español libre que conociese
la Liga o incluso al club.
¿Chávez, Ander?
Ya, pero yo no sé si...
Ni si la Real confía en Xavi,
ni si Xavi iría a la Real.
No lo sé, desconozco, pero si hubiese un
Jure Lopetegui, que ya no está porque está en Qatar,
igual esto se hubiese acelerado, ¿no?
Pero como no hay ningún nombre claro,
te la vas a jugar con un extranjero
en el sentido de
ese pero de adaptación,
es un club muy suyo también
en lo particular...
Creo que la dirección...
Viendo donde vienes.
La dirección deportiva es muy nueva.
Ha apostado por un entrenador
también debutante de la categoría.
Y muy nueva,
que no viene acertando con las apuestas
del mercado internacional que viene haciendo.
El otro día Susik volvió a quedar muy retratado
y eso que había sido el mejor del año pasado
y los nombres que han ido llegando.
Para tomar según qué decisiones,
primero tienes que tomarlas
o pensarlas, pero luego también
tienes que verte legitimado.
Y yo no sé si en ese punto vas a
arriesgar con un Marco Rose
de la vida o con un
nombre así que igual
hubiese tenido más sentido en verano.
¿Sabéis qué nombre ha sonado
por algún equipo español
del extranjero que acaba de quedar libre?
Grey Jam.
El amigo Grey Jam Potter.
Adri, fuimos tú y yo los que un día
creímos ver por Madrid
a Grey Jam Potter ¿no?
Ha estado Madrid y de hecho yo os confirmo
que estuvo viendo un partido del Getafe.
Estoy convencido de que era el Nahuel.
Sí, sí, sí.
Es que nos quedamos un día
mirando a un tío... A mí me gusta mucho
encontrar parecidos razonables.
Y le digo a Adri, mira, Grey Jam Potter.
Y empezamos a mirar y dijimos
¡Pero va a ser que sí, eh!
El pobre hombre que se llamaba
Ramón de apellido González y que iba
para su puesto de trabajo.
Ramón estaba comprando el país ahí tranquilo.
Espectacular.
Tercera cuestión.
Una cosa solo con lo de Grey Jam Potter.
Grey Jam Potter ha tenido varias oportunidades
de entrenar fútbol español.
Villarreal Sevilla
y cuando estuvo en el Hostess Tunes
también le entrevistó el español.
Y una última cosa.
Ha quedado libre.
Pero recordad que en la Premier está el Gardening.
El periodo de Gardening.
Que si fichas protocolo
pierdes la pasta que te está pagando el equipo
en cuestión.
Y claro, el West Ham le estará pagando un buen...
Un buen dinero.
Tercera cuestión de Inception1923.
Quiera abrir un melón.
Este buen hombre.
Brian Zaragoza es un blue
y dice tras su explosión
en Granada
y luego un destello en Pamplona y la nada en Vigo
estas primeras jornadas.
Dice, tengo la sensación de que
es un jugador que solo va a rendir bien en un sitio
en donde él se sienta plenamente a gusto.
Y dice plenamente a gusto fuera del campo.
En el sentido de, bueno, pues
tener los condicionantes.
Creo que tanto deportivos como emocionales.
Yo debo decir que estoy muy decepcionado
con el rendimiento de Brian.
Creo que ha habido momentos en los que ha entrado en Vigo
donde estaba para ganar el partido
el otro día ante Atlético en Madrid
y se quedaba muy lejos.
La segunda vuelta ante Osasuna fue mala
después de un impacto inicial muy bueno.
No soy de los que creen
que solo juega bien ante el Barça
que sí que es verdad que los grandes partidos
los ha hecho ante el Barça con Granada y Osasuna.
Pero sí que es verdad que
hace un añito que no le vemos.
Yo creo que se ha ido muy rápido con él.
Se le ficha
al Bayern
al tener 3, 4, 5
partidos buenos en primera
después de haber subido con el Granada.
Y yo creo que es que tampoco ha tenido demasiado tiempo
para terminar de hacer pie.
Es verdad que ya son 23 años
que Osasuna
ese inicio se ve truncado también por la lesión.
Pero no le ve raro a Les.
Es que transmite como
no estar bien.
No sé cómo decirlo.
Porque no es cabreado ni frustrado.
Es una situación que está...
No sé.
Mira, fíjate, está intentando más regates que nunca
pero le están saliendo menos que nunca.
Está en un momento en el que yo creo
y además esto me dio la sensación en Vallecas
que lo pude ver en directo
y es como que dentro del relacionismo
de Giralde
él no se siente bien.
Yo creo que él es un futbolista
y perdón por lo que voy a decir
pero él es un jugador
que no entiende el juego.
Y es que el jugador entiende que si está pinchado en banda
tiene más espacio y tiempo
para recibir y controlar
y entonces a partir de ahí genera la superioridad.
Pero yo creo que dentro de lo que propone Giralde
me parece que es un futbolista contracultural
que muchas veces
los futbolistas contraculturales te sirven
para reventar al rival en momentos en los que
el fútbol no termina de fluir
y yo creo que es lo que esperaba Giralde
pero es que ahora mismo ni está haciendo fluir al Celta
con su juego ni le está dando desborde.
Total. Esto que dice Alex
creo que es clave porque todos veíamos en Brian
un atajo
para el buen juego del Celta.
Es decir, que Brian fuese el futbolista
que como dice Alex te reventase al rival
cuando recibe en banda
que el Celta debía conseguir que el balón llegase a la banda izquierda
en uno para uno
con Brian y su lateral.
Y en esa situación que fuese el futbolista
que tenía que aportarse esa calidad diferencial
para desbordar y poner el centro
o sacar el disparo y no lo está siendo
y Giralde lo está probando incluso hasta por derecha.
No lo está limitando solo al costo de izquierda
porque por derecha tampoco lo estamos viendo rendir
a buen nivel.
Ojalá remonte el vuelo porque hasta el momento
es uno de los pichajes bacalao de lo que va a decir.
Bueno, pero si acaba por
no funcionar en el Celta
yo es un jugador por el que apostaría. Yo creo que tiene un talento
por el que merece la pena apostar
independientemente de cómo le vaya en el Celta.
Entonces yo por ahí, contestando a la pregunta
no me parece que sea un bluff
por muy mal que pueda salir su etapa en el Celta
vamos si sigue por donde va vas a ir mal.
Yo creo que se le cerrará alguna puerta.
No lo tengo claro
porque no hay tanto
futbolista de ese perfil y realmente
Brian está en un escalón
bastante lógico. O sea, lo que eso es una Celta
es decir, equipos que están entre
vamos a decir el octavo y el
decimotiercer puesto, ese rango más o menos
de la clasificación creo que es un rango lógico.
Lo que pasa es que es verdad
que pasa de Granada a Bayern muy rápido
y pasa de Bayern a Osasuna muy rápido también
pero este escalón a mí me parece lógico.
Y sí que creo que es una oportunidad perdida para él
si no aprovecha en vivo porque me pareció un
contexto magnífico para
crecer, para desarrollarse y para
dar un nuevo paso adelante.
El Bayern queda muy lejos
creo que ninguno aquí
lo veía mucho
ni piensa que vaya a volver a
un equipo de ese escalafón
pero entre el Bayern y Osasuna
barra Celta hay muchos escalafones
hay muchos escalones intermedio por los
que podía pasar. Pero bueno, yo también
creo que no es un bluffer y eso que estoy decepcionado.
Sergio Zapata
pregunta interesante, yo creo que nos
había hecho alguien en un Papa o Mama
pero invita a la reflexión
después de los últimos partidos
de Dani Ceballos en el Real Madrid.
Ya decimos que empieza el círculo
Dani Ceballos, esta rueda
donde el Madrid tiene
problemas, sale Dani
Ceballos, el Madrid mejora, Dani
Ceballos nos gusta, Dani Ceballos se lesiona
el Madrid no ficha nadie y es así.
Llevamos así los últimos dos años.
Pues pregunta Sergio Zapata
¿Creéis que al Madrid le vendría mejor
el Xavi Alonso jugador que el Xavi Alonso
entrenador?
Por completar el círculo llega el verano
Dani Ceballos se deja querer por el Betis
No se va el Betis
Ese círculo ya es el acabose
Ese círculo ya me tiene a mi matado
Ese es el círculo completo
de Dani Ceballos
Bueno, por responder a la pregunta
el Xavi Alonso futbolista
le sentaría muy bien
al Real Madrid actual
100%
Pero de más mal, sobre todo porque
el Xavi Alonso futbolista ya sabes la certeza
que es y el Xavi Alonso entrenador
a ver
si, pero no puede con la certeza
del Xavi Alonso jugador y además
es que ese perfil de jugadores
es que encajaría
No obstante me parece una muy buena
pregunta porque el Madrid necesitaba un perfil
de entrenador como Xavi Alonso
Es más moderno, abierto otro futbol
En la máxima élite
o sea cuando tienes acceso a los mejores
jugadores del mundo siempre un jugador
de, pues es un candidato a ganar
un balón de oro como fue Xavi Alonso en su día
va a pesar más que cualquier
entrenador. Otra cosa son
equipos más de autor, donde dices
oye, quitas al entrenador y
a ver qué pasa con esto
Ya estamos todos pensando en el mismo
¿En cuál?
No es Getafe
Yo creo que en el 99%
de los casos
prefieres a un crack
que a un grandísimo entrenador
No te cambian más cosas
Aquí casa perfectamente con la necesidad
Ojo, que tampoco sé
si teniendo a
Xavi Alonso y creyendo en
Xavi Alonso
es exactamente
el perfil que encajaría ahí
Creo que si al Xavi Alonso igual te llevaría a quitar a
Xavi Alonso y a jugar ahí con otro futbolista
Pero sí que es verdad
que el Madrid necesita un jugador en base de la jugada
que organize y ordena el juego
Es que no tiene más misterio
Haciendo la del titiritero con Xavi Alonso
Diciéndole, oye ahora para arriba, ahora para abajo
Bueno, es que igual
con la banda que a mí me da la risa
Yo no sé si encaja con el Madrid
esa idea, pero Xavi Alonso
en el Mónaco con Fofana
era el Sami Quedira de Fofana
Y digo Sami Quedira porque
era con quien jugaba Xavi Alonso
No creo que se pueda compasar
Pero sí que
sería un jugadorazo
Yo sigo creyendo que hay perfiles
para que el Madrid invierta ahí
aunque sea un dinero importante
Lo hubiese sido Martín Zubimendi
Lo sería Wharton
Y seguro que hay jugadores
que por perfil, quizás no por nivel
pero por perfil, mejorarían
notablemente al Real Madrid porque ya lo hace Dani Ceballos
Al final el problema de Dani Ceballos lo decimos siempre
siempre son las lesiones
Luego habría que ver
Y ahí la cuestión de nivel también
Pero eso lo podríamos hablar
para luego ganar en Champions
Pero para ser competitivo en Liga
y para ser un equipo estable
No creo que perdiese
por Dani Ceballos
Creo que igual no ganaría por Dani Ceballos
Pero es que al final
esa falta de ese jugador
Yo creo que el Madrid tiene jugadores para ganar
sin necesitar al mejor futbolista del mundo
Lo de para que es que no tira nadie
Cuando Dani Ceballos se lesiona
Entonces creo que por ahí va el tema
Pinichulo
¿Cómo veis el buen nivel del Betis?
Juegadores como Cucho, Abdeo, Fornals
jugando a un nivel muy alto
y situando al equipo en otro escalón
Y pregunta, ¿mérito de Pellegrini, Nahuel?
Bueno, totalmente
Es que, a ver
Yo creo que tanto Cucho como Fornals
creo que siempre han jugado a un nivel
bastante regular
Ahora mismo está en su mejor momento en el Betis
Pero Abde
Yo hasta la temporada pasada lo daba por una causa
perdida
Y el control de la jugada
del segundo gol del Betis el otro día
Brutal
Es una barbaridad de hablar de un futbolista
al que le ha cambiado la cara completamente
Ya acabó muy bien la pasada temporada
Arrancado como un tiro en esta
Y está siendo el Abde que
creíamos, que imaginábamos en Osasuna
Y creo que es el que
más ha mejorado
respecto a lo que ha sido su nivel previo en este Betis
Y detrás del nivel
de Fornals también
Imano de Pellegrini
Para mí el que más
Yo creo que al principio
a Fornals se le notaba mucho
que era un media punta jugando más atrás
que arriesgaba compases que no debía arriesgar
que soltaba cuando no tocaba
Creo que ha ido creciendo
en el dueño de la posición
Pero por eso
lo que decía Sadri
creo que da en el clavo
otro entrenador no le da
10 partidos a Fornals
Lo intentaba encajar en banda
o en la media punta
O lo pone dos veces y lo quitan el tercero
Fue el gran perjudicado por la llegada
de Anthony
Es que no es su hueco en el once
Tengo curiosidad hablando de Fornals
por ver cuál va a ser el rol de Fornals
cuando regrese Isco
No es tan fácil bajar a recirca
entre centrales
con un protagonismo grande
que es lo que hacía Isco
Yo creo que el equipo más titular
es Fornals San Rabat
en derecha Anthony
en la media punta Isco
en la izquierda Abde
y arriba Cucho
Yo creo que es lo que va a probar
salvo que Nelson de Osa
tire alguna puerta
por la que todavía no se ha colado
Me estoy preguntando por Pellegrini
porque tiene que renovar
y hay mucho debate
en la Sevilla Bética
por este tema
y me parece que esto de Fornals
de Cucho
habla bastante de Pellegrini
porque es un entrenador
que se me entienda bien
más de jugadores que de equipo
Creo que mejora los equipos
mejorando a los futbolistas
es uno de esos artesanos
que es un futbolista que le da confianza
y que les permite
crear con su fútbol lo que otros crean
con la pizarra
caso de Xavi Alonso que venimos a hablar de él
Creo que por eso el nombre de Fornals
me parece tan bueno para valorar todo lo que ha conseguido
Manuel Pellegrini en el Real Betis-Balompié
Yo creo que además
Pellegrini le da a sus futbolistas libertad
y les permite también a ellos
tomar decisiones en el campo
que les convierte en un equipo
muy impredecible
Cuando se sientan a ver al Betis
dicen
¿Cómo les atacamos?
Si de repente te presionan arriba
de repente repliegan un poquito más
de repente te esperan
pero si te esperan te pillan a la espalda
porque tienen buenos lanzadores al espacio
porque tienen jugadores que hagan muy bien esa profundidad
con jugadores que aguantan la pelota muy bien de espaldas
Es un equipo complicadísimo
tanto analizar como posteriormente
detectar esas debilidades
y cuando tienen los futbolistas
y tienen una determinación
en ebullición
pues son capaces de generar situaciones
como la segunda parte en Cornella
como momentos del partido central de Sassouna
en definitiva unos partidos en los que el equipo
está muy por delante
y además se ha dado la circunstancia
que esto Fajardo lo ha entendido a perfección
Es decir, Pellegrini
¿Qué tipo de entrenadores?
Pellegrini que necesita, jugadores que sepan
en el terreno de juego administrarse ellos mismos
porque Pellegrini es esa dirección de campo
y cuando no llegan, digo, Laínez
por eso sí que estamos viendo que de Osa igual
le pueda costar un poquito más
pero los que no le cuesta adaptarse es a los Amrabat
a los Fornals
a los Santos
Yo creo que es legítimo pensar
que el Betis llegado a este punto
igual con un entrenador
más pizarrita
aunque nosotros cuando decimos pizarrita
parece que son los que nos gustan
a nosotros nos gustan todos los tipos de entrenadores
realmente, pero bueno, nos entendemos
y si te pones de flechitas y de juego posicional y demás
tu puedes entender que ahí puede estar el siguiente nivel
pero es que me parece informe
a Manuel Pellegrini
yo entiendo de verdad la duda que puede tener ahora mismo
la dirección deportiva del Betis y el club
lo puedo entender, lo puedo entender porque a más
hace un año, más o menos por estas fechas
quizás un poquito más tarde
nosotros mismos nos preguntábamos si
si se había acabado
pero es que ahora mismo
yo no me veo
creo que supone un riesgo mayúsculo
Pellegrini contó lo que ha conseguido
que ha conseguido estabilizar también
respecto a la presidencia, a las direcciones deportivas
que han sido muy buenas
todos planas, cordón, evidentemente
ahora Fajardo, pero Pellegrini
ha conseguido estabilizar a un equipo
que incluso era ascensor, por mucho que el Betis
era un histórico de primera
venía siendo ascensor en el siglo XXI
y ojo
que tenía también sus problemas con las inscripciones
no lo olvidemos
que hace 3 temporadas
se planta creo que es un partido en elche
en el que no sabía quién iba a jugar
4 jugadores iba a tener
Alex, que pasaron de Luis Felipe hace 2
creo que es en casa, Betis Elche
Betis Elche, cierto
creo que es el debut en primera edición de John Donald
que estuvo
te impactó a tuya, eh
te marcó
no, no
es que recuerdo que es el elche
que acabó bajando
siendo muy colista con 6 entrenadores
eso es
consulta rápida
renovación a Pellegrini si o no
si o sin dudarlo, si
depende de las condiciones
entiendo también las reservas de
72 años
a ver que contrato le vamos a firmar a Pellegrini
que no tiene pinta de querer ir de año en año
vale, pero si te voy a dar yo
las condiciones, vale
2 años
y está
como bordalas
es el mejor entrenador de los 5 pagados de España
el cuerpo técnico de Manuel Pellegrini
tiene un porcentaje
amplio de la masa salarial
y esto es información, no opinión
y vosotros sabéis como tengo la información
y es delirante, así que avancemos
ostras
yo creo que lo tienes que hacer
porque es el mejor entrenador
al menos de la historia reciente
de este siglo seguro
yo creo que en esa pelea
mano a mano con Serra Ferrer
cada vez tiene más argumentos Pellegrini
le renuevas
pero
con reparos
yo creo que el aficionado también se ponga
de parte del club de decir
calma
que quiero que fulmine a Pellegrini
y le queda año y medio de contrato a ver qué hago
tiene que entenderlo, además creo que es
un momento legítimo para preguntárselo
y yo entiendo a Pellegrini
es una presión y tampoco es algo que puedes dejar
para abril o mayo como pasó en la real sociedad
creo que es algo que tiene que quedar resuelto
en enero
pero no me sobran estos dos
tres primeros meses de la temporada
para oler el ambiente
ver cómo está el vestuario
cómo responden los fichajes con Pellegrini
que han llegado muchos jugadores
es una plantilla que ha cambiado muchísimo
no me sobra este tiempito
es inteligente Manu Fajardo tomándoselo
yo lo que digo es
¿Betis buscó la opción
pizarrita pan en quita con ruby?
no?
¿cómo terminó?
el tema
con ruby fuera más pronto que tarde
y sobre todo
y sobre todo yo creo
la pizarra pan en quita era aquí que se tiene
pero tampoco eso es pizarra pan en quita
porque nosotros somos muy de Pellegrini
claro
aunque no hable
y muy de bordalas
es que no
nos gusta el buen fútbol
y si es con flechitas bien
y si es con circulitos también
lo bueno del fútbol es que
cada uno lo ve
lo siente y lo vive de una manera
y si tú eres capaz de
trasladar esa manera de sentirlo
a tus jugadores y de llevarlo
a buenos resultados
es un buen entrenador y nos va a gustar
coherencia que es lo que alabábamos el otro día
con Matías Almeida
y Diosincrácia del club
y entrenador
Carlos Amigot
es Andoni
el entrenador español más infravalorado
su trabajo con el rayo fue tremendo
y con el bormoz está siendo ya impresionante
yo tengo la impresión de que no está
infravalorado simplemente está esperando
ese gran proyecto
para dar el siguiente nivel
pero yo creo que a los
claro hombre si se lo preguntas
a Ramón Fernández
ese hombre que se parecía a Graham Potter
igual iraola
pero si lo preguntas en el mundillo del fútbol
de los medios de comunicación
yo no creo que Andoni iraola esté infravalorado
creo que se le tiene como un
fantástico entrenador que va a hacer una carrera
larguísima y exitosa
se le ha sondeado yo creo que para todos los clubes grandes
de premier que han cambiado
de entrenador para Tottenham
para Manchester United
para todos
yo sinceramente creo que lo único
es que como está en el bormoz
que probablemente
no se le vea tanto como
otro que está infravalorado en España
que es Mikel Arteta
que al final es un entrenador que te ha metido
en equipos semifinales que te ha metido
a pelear de toda tu, Conta City y Liverpool
entonces yo creo que simplemente
lo que le falla es que está en el bormoz
y es verdad que al proyecto del bormoz
lo ha hecho crecer una barbaridad también tuvo suerte
porque creo que estuvo los cinco
primeros partidos sin ganar
los primeros fue una barbaridad que no estuvo sin ganar
le mantuvieron en el cargo
de partir ahí para arriba
pero sí
yo creo que o sea infravalorado no
simplemente probablemente desconocido
claro es que es eso
es que es un debate muy recurrente
pasar con cualquier jugador o entrenador que lo hace bien
fuera del foco
ya no fuera de España sino
fuera de España y fuera de la Champions
yo creo que en su día
Unai Emery estuvo infravalorado
pero creo que el caso de ir ahora es
que pasa con cualquier jugador
español que haya hecho carrera fuera
que ha pasado Silva con el propio
arteta jugador, pasó con Dani Olmo
ha pasado con Fabián
ha pasado con Cucurella
pasaba con Xavi Alonso futbolista
que coge otra dimensión con el Real Madrid
entonces bueno yo creo que hasta el fondo
es natural pero tampoco deberíamos hacer
cruces de que estaba infravalorado
que la gente no siga al bormoz
porque además si vamos a decir que el chingú rival verde
decide marcharse esta temporada
bueno hay unas selecciones
en el horizonte no sé si ya este verano o el siguiente
no recuerdo bien
pero vamos Andoni Raola sería carta ganadora
pero es que igual
Andoni Raola antes de que llegue
el Atleti Club, Andoni Raola va a entrar
al Atleti Club, eso creo que
lo sabemos todos
y lo sabe todo el mundo
que a poco que conozca el Atleti Club y Andoni Raolas
esto es una obviedad pero es verdad
Andoni Raola antes del Atleti Club
entrena un equipo con más
aspiraciones que el Atleti Club
no sé si me estoy explicando igual
llega el verano que viene
me lo invento el Manchester United
y va al Manchester United que en teoría
debería tener más aspiraciones que el Atleti Club
y luego entra
el Atleti Club porque es Andoni Raola
que es una leyenda
es el típico entrenador que lo hace bien en un equipo de la Premier
y suena para cualquier Big Six
en problemas
el que lo infravalora es
que no conoce la situación de ir a Ola
y lo que están trabajando en la Premier
por cierto
este tipo de entrenador
a mi me encajaría mucho sonando
porque no suena, cuando se habla de Diego Pablo
Simeone se ha hablado de muchos
entrenadores en los últimos años
se hablaba de Sergio Consi, se sudía
o lo mencionaba yo, me acuerdo que
el Toto Beriz en su día cuando estaba
en Celta me encajaba bastante
y se habla mucho ahora de ex futbolistas
como Felipe Luis, hay muchos
el propio Fernando Torres, etc
pero a mi un Andoni Raola
me parecería
una actualización de
libretto
ahondando en la misma idea pero de otra manera
me molaría
sería interesante
estaba pensando ya que
Raola no es el entrenador español más infravalorado
¿quién puede serlo?
lo era Valverde
en la Liga
a mi me parece muy infravalorado
Manolo González
si estoy de acuerdo
pero todos valoramos a Manolo
no?
yo creo que tiene menos prensa
pero coño es que llevo un año
en primera y ya salva al español la última jornada
y aun así creo que
pasa algo con Manolo que es que
como es un poco bruto hablando
y no tiene ningún tipo de filtro
y la historia del autobús
parece que es
un sandoval de la vida
y creo que
el español de Manolo está demostrado ser un equipo
y el táctico muy rico
creo que le pasa eso
y igual puede estar por ahí
pero creo que eso más que infravalorado
también tiene un toque de condescendencia
cuando un entrenador llega
con la historia de Manolo se le habla
de forma condescendiente
cuando dices chatu
¿tú sabes lo que ha tenido que hacer Manolo para llegar aquí?
es una condescendencia
pero creo que no es tanto la historia del autobús
se la han repetido hasta
se la han repetido y la de que viene
y la de que jodé
la de que ha entrenado
que era la primera vez que entrenaban
la primera vez
ya hemos convivido casi un año y medio
con Manolo en la elite del fútbol español
ya fue
no se le saca tanto
pero creo que en el día a día
justo mira me ha apagado la cámara Manolo
silencia no Miranda
silencia
ha dicho te callas
te callas
eh
no pues eso
que para explicarse es un poco bruto
y me parece perfecto
y creo que le hace un tío super carismático
pero ya digo
por como se expresa parece
un simple motivador
y creo
que nada más lejos de la realidad
la pregunta que dice Adri es muy interesante
y creo que no tiene una única respuesta
porque al final que pasa con los entrenadores
les sobrevaloramos muy rápido
y aquí yo al menos me incluyo
cuando hace un gran trabajo
y le infravaloramos muy rápido cuando llega un trabajo malo
y sabemos que muchas veces
no siempre depende todo del entrenador
lo digo porque creo que Jülen Lopetegui
antes de firmar por el Sevilla estaba tremendamente
infravalorado
incluso hubo bastantes criticas cuando llega
porque creo que Ernesto Valverde
cuando llega a la etapa en el FC Barcelona
como si Ernesto Valverde lo hubiese tocado en una tómbola
cuando Ernesto Valverde tenía ya un currículum
espectacular
creo que con Marcelino hay un tramo
antes de Valencia donde también pasa
entonces quiero decir
como que hay muchos byvanes
eh
donde llega ese punto
yo creo que por ejemplo que un Aiemer
y no haya entrenado a alguien del Big 3 en España
me parece
pero creo que
hay una circunstancia en el sentido de
si Diego Paulo Simeone no existiese
hubiese entrenado a un Aiemer y al Atlético Madrid
el Madrid creo que tiene
otro tipo y el Barça también
es que como Madrid y Barça son tan particulares
a Madrid y a Barça
en los últimos 10 años y tampoco me voy a poner a dar nombres
le han entrenado
entrenadores que son peores que un Aiemer y
esa es la realidad
lo que vale es que es un tema de perfil muchas veces
sigue mirando a los 20 equipos de primera división
porque creo que
por ejemplo hay que
valorar muy bien a entrenadores que
que lo han tenido muy
complicado y que al final
acabado saliendo pero que han hecho un buen trabajo
a mi por ejemplo me parece el caso de Pimienta
yo creo que Pimienta va a volver a entrenar en primera división
y es un técnico que tengo ganas de volver a ver
totalmente de acuerdo
que vamos
viendo los 20 equipos
a mi me cuesta pensar en un técnico
más infravalorado que Manolo
es cierto que Calero
es un técnico que me encanta
hemos hablado mucho
de girar el dcd
yo creo que por ahí se les ha quitado esa etiqueta
acaban de conseguir transplicaciones europeas
contra pronóstico
sabes quien creo que estaba infravalorado
hay que volver a decir situaciones y momentos
Michel
tiene dos equipos
dos ascensos
los equipos no terminan de funcionar
en primera y se le infravalora mucho
y luego llega un tercer intento
y al principio también se le infravalora
incluso se puede decir
que después de su etapa en Girona
se le puede llegar a sobrevalorar en algún momento
creo que con los entrenadores
sobrereaccionamos bastante
más que con los jugadores
por ejemplo ahora que está Colista en Mallorca
todos tenemos en buena estima
el trabajo de Iagova
y somos muy conscientes de que el trabajo que tiene
por adelante esta temporada hasta donde le dejen
es muy complicado
y no es descartable
y no cambia la situación
pero
es un técnico de primera
a lilo de lo que decía
de Pimienta
el caso de Pimienta
podría semejarse un poco
a lo que ocurrió en su vida con Javi Gracia
también tiene muy buena pinta
su trabajo está infravalorado en el Málaga
Diego Martínez
para mi es el gran bluff
de entrenador
que le tenía más arriba
el mayor discípulo de una emery
y no ha funcionado
se me ha caído una barbaridad en las últimas 3 etapas
el tema es
que hablamos mucho de cuando
un jugador elige mal su destino
pero creo que las elecciones condenan mucho más a los entrenadores
que en el caso de Javi Gracia
te la pegas con el Valencia
en el caso de Pimienta te la pegas con un Sevilla
y ya parece que bajas muchos escalones de golpe
pero
y tu lo dices muchas veces y es verdad
dices a menudo
hay 20 banquillos
para muchos entrenadores
pero encima luego cuántas oportunidades
como esa que tuvo Javi Gracia en Valencia
y la que tuvo el Sevilla por mucho que sean envenenadas
cuántas oportunidades recibes
porque yo lo pienso también incluso con directores deportivos
a mi me sorprendió que Víctor Horta
asumiera en el Sevilla
pero luego piensas y dices
que es el Sevilla
es que también se puede decir de cordón ahora que le está yendo muy bien
porque la situación era muy jodida
pero es que es el Sevilla FC
antes que recordabais
la Real Sociedad con Iagova
que si no os recuerdo mal
asume como interino y luego se queda
pero si es el jugador de la Real Sociedad
se tiene que marcharos a Zona en segunda división
no, es Numancia
ah, Numancia, perdón
Numancia y luego Zona
que tiene el tema del ascenso aquel, no?
no, que das pasitos para atrás muy rápido
y que sales de la rueda muy rápido
chicos, habéis solo un nombre
que creo que vamos a estar todos de acuerdo en infravalorado
y pasamos a la siguiente pregunta
verás que mala pinta tiene esto
nooo
Pep Guardiola
Jürgen, no?
José Luis Mendilibar
si
yo creo que se ha hecho justicia el tío
claro
pero se ha hecho justicia
de la forma más tramposa posible
que es con las victorias
o sea, no tramposa
pero se valora porque no ha habido más cojones que valorarlo
sabes lo que quiero decir?
te ganas la Europa League con Sevilla
te ganas la confre
si, si
entrenar para eso, Nahuel
pero salvar cinco veces al Eibar o cuatro
es ganar
no, no, está claro
no tengo claro que ganar la Europa League con Sevilla
sea más meritorio que las cuatro salvaciones con el Eibar
así lo digo
no lo tengo claro
pero rendir con dos posibilidades
tenemos que entender
a los entrenadores a los que le llega una oferta suculenta
a un club superior
y lo aceptan
estaba pensando en Paco López
que son cuatro temporadas tremendas
con el Levante
el final de la cuarta, el principio de la quinta
se le va todo al garete
y lo siguiente tiene que hacer es entrenar a la segunda división
que decir
el propio Mendilibar
cinco veces son al Eibar
si las sexta bajas
la gente se queda con que has bajado con el Eibar
hay que aprovechar los momentos
vamos con la séptima cuestión
debatido bonito el que ha salido aquí
aquí también es de infravalorados
pero creo que aquí tiene sentido
Aitor Mundt dice
os parece que Moises Caicedo es uno de los jugadores más infravalorados del mundo
sino el que más
da exhibiciones partido tras partido en ataque y en defensa
es un ganador de duelo espectacular
y el otro día le dio una vacunada premium a mi Liverpool
aquí creo que
pero juegan el Chelsea
Moises Caicedo
ya ha ganado el mundial de clubes
y pago la pasta al Chelsea
yo estoy aquí de acuerdo
es el jugador de la premia
hay mucha gente
se cruza Moises Caicedo por la calle y no sabe quién es
fuera de
el dono Inglaterra
el que lo infravalora
es por desconocimiento
no porque
lo vea
pero por ejemplo
Nacho González
pero Nacho González
esto lo dice que en el
contexto premier
no fútbol español
que también se le infravalora
y es verdad que cuando tú ves
comentarios
nominaciones 11
como lo queramos decir
yo sí que creo que le lastra el Chelsea
a Moises Caicedo
porque el jugador es colosal
esta temporada es el futbolista de la premier
que más entradas ha completado
que más intercepciones ha realizado
además es el jugador
también con más recuperaciones
el que tiene en un mismo partido más
recuperaciones y
cuidado al dato
tres goles llevaban esta premier el último que le ha marcado
al Chelsea en el partido del sábado
impresionante
si le ha marcado al Chelsea estará
impresionante pero valen también
los en propia puerta valen
he dicho al Chelsea no?
al Liverpool perdonad
ya sabéis que no puedo decir una frase sin equivocarme
entonces
un tipo que la temporada pasada
decía maresca
venga va te vamos a poner
de lateral derecho
cumple lateral derecho sobrecargándolo
en el centro del campo en ese sistema híbrido
oye que
necesitamos que llegues un poquito más a la frontal
oye que mira que es que a Enzo le apetece
llegar ahora a la frontal encárgate tú
y el campo propio me encargo yo del campo propio
y luego un jugador
chicos ha sido protagonista
la mejor selección ecuatoriana
una de las mejores de la historia a mi sinceramente
me parece que el 2024-2025
de Moises Caicedo lo tiene todos
ahora mismo te diría que
y de hecho lo iba pensando esta mañana a la radio
no saca el debate bueno la mañana
del lunes a la radio
ahora mismo el mejor
centro campista del mundo junto a Pedro y Vitiña
para mi Moises
pues ahí tienes la opinión de
Alés de Llano
Marc Piquer
creéis que Víctor Goque
podría volver algún grande de Europa
con su nivel en Palmeiras porque ha sido
volver a Brasil y
y romper
a marcar de nuevo yo confío
en Víctor Goque no sé si para un grande
pero confío lleva dos meses
chavales que está la cosa fina
eh espérate que estoy
dibujando el dato claro
que es decir Palmeiras paga
en torno a 30 no
le devuelvo un poquito la moneda del Barça
con muchas comillas claro
quien va a pagar 40 45
bueno se pagan
que tienes que pagar más no
mira el United
contad conmigo eh contad conmigo vale
desde el 10 desde el 10 de agosto
vale vale 1 2
3 4 5
5 6
7 8 9
9 9 9 goles
y
queréis que contemos las asistencias chicos
si claro si si si
venga porque va 1 2 3 4
y alza
9 goles y 4 asistencias
desde el 10 de agosto
not bad no?
marcando en cuartos de final de Copa Libertadores
aquí el problema
es que le hemos visto en el Betis
que era un entorno que podía parecer propicio
y no controla un balón
no hace una buena definición
no sé que ha pasado en Palmeiras
yo soy un jugador de verdad en el que creo porque es muy rápido
muy incisivo se desmarca bien
osea quiero decir yo veo cualidades
yo veo las cualidades por las que pago en su día el Barça
independientemente de que fuese un error
pero le veo y digo vale lo entiendo
pero joder es que de cara a puerta
es un desastre a día de hoy
al menos hasta el Betis es un desastre
antes
de volver a un grande
del fútbol europeo
estamos pasando por la Mili de una Stumbilla
o algo así
que tiene la posibilidad de pagar lo que va a pedir Palmeiras
para traspasarlo
y de verlo ahí
primero otra vez en un equipo de un escalón intermedio
en Europa antes de un gigante
son 20 años
es que son 20 años
es muy joven
pero es que volvemos a lo mismo
hay que meter mucha pasta
y le paso en su día por ejemplo a Gabigol
que le caía los goles en Brasil
pero en el intervalo es futbolista
le paso a
no se por ejemplo a Pedro
al 9 de Flamengo que hemos visto varias veces con Brasil
pues que es jugo en Italia y que tampoco rindo
y que tiene sentido lo que dices porque
si Vitor Roque tiene 20 años
pero también es que hay un
jugadiño
que ahora tiene 17
y que igual el Aston Villa de turno
por esos 35 millones los pierde invertir
en jugadiño que en Vitor Goque
y que volvemos al debate que teníamos mucho durante el Mundial de Clubes
que Brasil paga muy bien
que hay gente
que no infravalora
que no puede renunciar a pasta por ser el 9 de Palmeiras
que eres uno de los equipos más grandes de Brasil
que estás pagado como cristo
para ir a jugar a
yo que se, la Fiorentina
como le paso a Pedro
o el Aston Villa
que si, que cojonudo Aston Villa
pero cambias Brasil por Birmingham
un equipo que no aspira a títulos
o de forma tan directa
por Palmeiras
uno de los equipos dominantes
en el último lustro en el fútbol
sudamericano
es que tiene mucho sentido
si lo trasladamos a baloncesto
que yo siempre hago esta
porque la relación
FIBA-NBA no es exactamente la relación Europa-Sudamerica
pero es verdad
que había un punto donde parecía que era un ascenso llegar a Europa
por condiciones económicas y deportivas
pero es que ese ascenso ya no es tan real
es un ascenso si vas al brasileño Miguel
es un ascenso si vas al Bayern
claro, es lo que digo
si vas al Dortmund es un ascenso
pues ya te lo empiezas a plantear
va en la ambición del futbolista
si Vitor Roque quiere ser uno de los mejores
del mundo
tendrá que venir a Europa
no va a ser en el fútbol brasileño
solo ha habido un futbolista en los últimos años
que se haya saltado a esa norma
y es Neymar
es el mejor de todo el equipo en Brasil
pero es tu visión
como criado en Europa
para Vitor Roque
criado en Brasil
pero Alex
Alex, pero seamos honestos
es una visión eurocentrista
pero para ser considerado uno de los mejores delanteros
del mundo tienes que venir a Europa
tú no puedes ser considerado uno de los mejores jugadores
del baloncesto si no ir a la NBA
esto es una realidad
quiero decir
es una visión del futbolista
pero también va en lo que a él le pueda dar
la haga feliz
claro
el Bayern de turno tiene que poner 45 kilos
por un futbolista que cuando estuvo en Europa
se la pegó en dos clubes diferentes
entonces quiero decir
es una apuesta arriesgada
que el chico se salga en Brasil
bueno al final esto tiene un debate
muy rico y ya lo haremos algún día
porque es verdad lo que dice
Nahuel a veces le puede compensar al futbolista
pero hay otras que no le compensan a nivel económico
ni a nivel deportivo
ni a nivel ambición salvo que
te lo plantes como un punto intermedio
hacia volver a un grande como en el que estuvo
Víctor Roque en el Fútbol Club Barcelona
nos quedan dos cuestiones
la penúltima
Viera 15 vs Fé
pregunta muy a largo plazo
importante, muy a largo plazo
no penséis en el mundial 2026
¿a qué selección le tenéis fe
para el mundial?
hay otras que no le faltan las escandinavas
y concreta las selecciones también
Turquía o Georgia
pero si tengo que destacar
una es Holanda aunque le falte más punch arriba
yo tengo una pedrada
también os digo perdonadme
pregunta de este mundial pero habla a largo plazo
así que más bien para este mundial
para que igual a nuestro hermano
además de las escandinavas les gustan las exageraciones
no bueno
yo también tengo una pedrada
la pregunta creo que es la cuenta B de Quintana
no
por lo de Turquía
a mi Turquía me gusta mucho
Gilly, Willer
a mi también
Kadioglu
te voy a decir para mí
la gran candidata
no mainstream
del mundial 2026
es
Marruecos
pero
Marruecos que viene
en el power ranking
claro le metió el power ranking hermano
bueno
ya veremos qué hace la copa de africa
esto es decir
belgica en 2018
claro y si nos preguntan qué plantilla mejor
Marruecos 2022 o Marruecos 2025
yo creo que nos quedamos con la de 2025
hombre
Marruecos 2025 cuidado y 2026
verás
antes
entonces
de qué estás hablando
claro
hombre
no te parece sorprendente
que Marruecos sea candidata
de las no mainstream
si quitas a las 8 que suenan siempre va a ganar
pues sí
entonces cuál era la pregunta
qué quieres que diga la pregunta
yo creo que
pues no
a Canabaro
a Canabaro va a poner a Bekistan
Japón
Japón va a ganar
pero lo gana
la pregunta no habla de mainstream
la pregunta es una mierda
y digo
Quintana la pregunta que has hecho con tu cuenta
culpa mía
por escribirla con la cuenta B y elegirla con la cuenta A
a ver
es que quiero decir
que en el mundo mundial yo concuerdo
en que
anda la cosa entre
Ecuador ya selección mencionada
y Marruecos de cara a
fuera de las
6, 7 que te va a decir todo el mundo de carrería
aunque no sepa nada de fútbol
ojo Ecuador que lo de marcar goles
se les resiste
pero a mí me gustaba pensar
porque este ha sido un debate siempre muy del fútbol
de la siguiente selección que va a ganar el mundial
la última fue la selección española
y siempre se hablaba de Estados Unidos
China
Japón y demás
yo creo que hay que volver un poco
a lo que se pensaba en los 90
porque yo creo que donde más se está creciendo
y donde más posibilidades hay de que haya una selección
ganadora por primera vez
es en África
ya sea por Marruecos ya sea por Nigeria
que creo que es una de las
potencias a medio plazo
más interesantes del mundo
en todos los sentidos
y creo que el hecho de que Marruecos
vaya teniendo cada vez más
futbolistas formados en Europa
pero que juegan con Marruecos
cuidado
porque ya vimos los resultados en el pasado mundial
y cuidado con Suiza a pesar de tener a todos lesionados
yo tengo ganas
yo tengo ganas de ver a Paraguay
a Paraguay de Gustavo Gómez
y Omar Alderete
el resultado
cortos
por tener Fiso poniendo la magia
yo quiero ver a Eslovaquia
que no creo que voy a ganar
pero apetece ver a Eslovaquia en el mundial
ya empezamos con Eslovaquia
claro claro
pero dilo
amiguitos
sí sí amiguitos
Tomas Rigo
le dio la victoria a Eslovaquia frente a Luxemburgo
muy de selección
lo de ganarle a Alemania
y irte 0-0 con Luxemburgo
pero menos mal que apareció Tomas
para marcar
creía que era un juego de palabras con Luxemburgo
pero no
era con Eslovaquia
¿sabéis quién ha convocado Nigeria
para que haga su debut?
a Cor Adams
mi nombre es
¿acor al revés?
acor al revés Roca
eso era mi nombre
alguna selección
que os apetezca ver
más allá de esto
es una lastima que no vaya a Venezuela
que molaba ver hasta que punto
ojo Tite que es el candidato que está sonando más
chiche chiche
chiche sería guay en la real sociedad
por ejemplo
está en las calles
de Donosti
no se veía tanta gente en la concha
desde que anunciaron a David Moyes
en la parte vieja ahí la gente
chiche chiche chiche
a la real sociedad se escapó Muriño
décima
será increíble
Alejandro Aguilar
¿qué equipo creéis que necesita?
y o
¿se puede beneficiar más del mercado
invierno? un saludo
no lo sé
otro de vuelta
pasaba
equipo que creéis que ahora
mismo llevamos 8 jornadas pero los directores deportivos
ya están trabajando en esto
más van a necesitar el mercado invierno
yo tengo dos candidatos
uno el que se quedó sin tiempo
última hora que es el Getafe
al cual sin tiempo y sin dinero
y otro que es el equipo
con la plantilla yo creo
más corta de una manera pretendida
¿qué es el equipo que le puede sentar en que es Osasuna?
ah
yo voy a haber dicho Oviedo
Oviedo lo necesita
yo Oviedo
creo que además
el Oviedo tiene
poderío
económico por la propiedad
para hacer alguna operación
interesante más teniendo en cuenta
que creo que el equipo necesita
si ahora mismo le dices a la aficionada
¿donde quiere reforzar al equipo?
como la portería te iría a todas las líneas
pregunto si la Real Sociedad
cambia de entrenador ¿esperáis?
porque la Real ha acudido al mercado invierno
en los últimos años desde la gestión Olave
con oportunidades de mercado
rollo Rafinha
por poner un nombre
pero claro nunca ha llegado en esta situación
desde que
destituyó a Garitano que creo que es el primer
año de la era Roberto Olave
no destituya un técnico que no sé si va a pasar con Sergio
Francisco, se está poniendo él
y el equipo de la Real Sociedad
no remonta el vuelo Sergio Francisco
llega un entrenador, queda o no el entrenador
algo diferente será
necesita X cosas
¿no puede ser un equipo de los de
aspirantes a Europa
que necesitan eso?
y que pueden, pero claro
igual también lo podemos decir otro equipo
yo creo que la Real Sociedad
tiene con que
te llamas dudas con otro equipo que yo creo que tiene
dinero para ir al mercado y que no la ha
comprado el Mallorca, si sigue metido ahí abajo
es el típico equipo que puede
verle los dientes al lobo y decir
oye ahora sí que
tengo que cambiar cosas
¿porque no confías en que los esté
cambiando ya yo en Mallorca?
no claro
es que confío poco en ti en general
Miguel, dicho esto
hay que recalcar que el Mallorca
ha tenido muy mal
calendario hasta ahora
yo confío en la resolución del
Mallorca
ahora va Miguel para allá
para hundirlo más
no hombre no
toda la suerte del mundo a Mallorca
tremendo juntar a Mallorca con el
mayor cabrón eh
woooooo
con cariño
con cariño siempre Miguel
por favor no me gusta el Inen
no
no quiero buscar trabajo vale
no me eches tío
no me eches